Speaker 1: So the brains of maggots seem to
be breaking over this news story related to
some classified documents that were left behind
at an office of then Vice President Joe Biden.
Now, I have made every effort, and it hasn't
been very difficult to be consistent about
this story.
Donald Trump should have.
And is it being investigated for his handling
of classified documents, including taking
a whole bunch of them to his house and then
lying about where they are and then avoiding
returning them and all these different things.
And Joe Biden should likewise be investigated.
Now, the circumstances, of course, are completely
different.
We're talking about a couple about a dozen
or so documents with Joe Biden.
And we're talking about, what, hundreds or
more with Trump.
We're talking about something with Joe Biden
where when his lawyers found out, they immediately
notified the National Archives, it was the
opposite with Trump.
There is no evidence whatsoever that Joe Biden
asked or was even involved in these documents
remaining where they were.
Whereas there is widespread testimony that
Donald Trump specifically said take these
documents down to Mar a Lago.
There's there are no similarities, but I'm
consistent.
Investigate every one and everything and see
where it shakes out.
Right wingers brains seemed to have been scrambled
by this.
Here is Ronny Jackson, who says he believes
these documents were found as part of a conspiracy
by Democrats to push Biden out before 2024.
Speaker 2: And they could be happening here.
Jean, is that I've been saying for a long
time that the Democrats are going to have
to figure out a way to get rid of Joe Biden.
They don't want this man to run for president
again.
He's a recipe for disaster in the next presidential
election.
So I think, you know, a lot of people thought
it would be a cognitive issue.
You know, I thought so as well.
But I thought, well, maybe they won't go down
there because that's admitting defeat, that
they put this cognitively incompetent man
in a position like the president, United States.
I said all along, I thought maybe they would
let the Hunter Biden thing go up a little
bit, but maybe this is what they're doing.
Maybe this is the first shot that they're
going to fire to try to get him in a position
where he ultimately has to resign or at least
has to decide that he's not going to run again.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, the reason this is very stupid is, of
course, number one, there's no evidence of
that.
But number two, it doesn't really make sense
because as I talked about at the top of the
show, why is Joe Biden a disaster in the sense
that in polling against Trump, Biden is mostly
winning?
Four 2024 Unemployment is the lowest it's
been in 50 years.
Inflation has come down six months in a row.
Wages are up.
The idea that it's obviously a disaster for
Biden to run isn't borne out by the facts.
Now, here's a Lena Haba, Trump's lawyer, who
says, What about her being special prosecutor
on Biden's boxes?
Of course, there are no boxes.
We're talking about 12, 12 documents.
Speaker 3: Alina, do you think this completely
exonerates Trump from the Merrick Garland
documents witch hunt?
I think so.
And I think that more importantly, we should.
Speaker 1: Oh, by the way, on this exoneration
thing, they don't seem to get that just because
someone else is being investigated for something,
it doesn't mean you're exonerated.
It's sort of I used this analogy yesterday
and it's so simple, but it's so, so emblematic
of this.
If I am accused of murder.
And then someone else is accused of murder.
I don't get to say I'm exonerated because
someone else is now being investigated for
murder.
That's the argument they're making here.
And it's a very silly argument.
Speaker 3: Point out one thing, very important.
Donald Trump was the sitting president of
the United States.
He had the ability to declassify the Presidential
Records Act applied to him.
Biden doesn't have that excuse.
He was the vice president.
Yes.
Now he's the sitting president.
But these are documents that were taken during
the Obama administration.
They are in places that are not secure.
He was a he was not a president at the time.
He had no right to them.
I saw an article today, I believe, and it
said that he had the presidential records
incorrect.
He was a vice president.
He's not afforded those protections and he
doesn't have the ability to do so.
So I think that this does help President Trump.
Quite honestly, I don't think President Trump
needed help because I don't think he did anything
wrong.
Speaker 1: We now, by the way, I know Alina
Habas, an attorney, the research, she says
the Presidential Records Act doesn't apply
to the vice president.
I believe it does.
The research I've been able to find says that
the Presidential Records Act of 1978 governs
both the president and vice president.
Maybe I'm misunderstanding that.
I don't.
Speaker 3: Know.
We're cooperating, as you know, and that matter
is underway.
Speaker 1: But they weren't cooperating.
Speaker 3: They have to show that they're
going to treat everybody the same.
And I would like to personally offer to be
the special prosecutor on Biden's boxes.
Speaker 1: Because there are no boxes because
we're talking about 12 documents that were
immediately told the National Archives were
immediately notified by Biden's lawyers.
Lastly, here's Claudia Tenney saying that
Biden's the biggest liar in American politics.
She may be forgetting about a guy who told
like 14,000 lies during his presidency.
Speaker 4: I give her credit because to be
the press secretary and have to lie for the
biggest liar in modern politics is quite an
extraordinary obligation and job.
I mean, what are you going to say?
He may not even know where they are.
But look, look, I give her credit.
Speaker 1: So that's Republican Congresswoman
Claudia Tenney.
Now, the story is Biden is the biggest liar
that is out there.
Their brains have been scrambled and it's
very, very easy to be consistent on this.
We say, oh, any time there is a question about
documents and presidents or former presidents
or vice presidents investigate it and then
go where the facts take you.
What we know about the facts of the Biden
situation and the Trump situation are so dramatically
different that it's laughable to suggest there
is even any similarity.
But again, investigate everyone.
Hunter Biden, investigate Hunter Biden.
It's just not an issue for the House of Representatives,
since it has nothing whatsoever to do with
politics or the Biden administration.
But if Hunter Biden broke some law with law
enforcement, investigate him, it's we.
This isn't about protecting Democrats.
It's about having some kind of consistent
standard about what we consider to be wrongdoing.